au lever on termine par une image
étonnante deux frères ya la bruce sur la
même scène ils se ressemblent comme deux
gouttes d'eau l'un c'est michel qu'on ne
présente plus l'autre ses marques et les
deux frères sont à la fiche du riche
convoiter une pièce de carlo goldoni que
l'on a pu découvrir au festival de
théâtre dans jour une oeuvre qui
convient tout à fait hostile de la
famille galabru reportage de gérard
d'alma et de jeanne cherhal
mais sinon la prédiction de la bleue
dans un couloir que tu sais que son sein
d'accor regardez bien pour la première
fois ensemble sur scène les deux frères
galabru marques ea médecins de métier
revient à ses premières amours de
comédiens amateurs
il a des dons c'est sûr et puis son
professeur n'est autre que son grand
frère michel
ariel plus facile
vous pouvez dire que tu es pas quoi hier
il a été engagé pour s'ouvrir plus
facile vous pouvez dire t'as pas peur là
alors vas-y vas-y tu y avait rien les
vans hui de ce prix une visite pour
l'oiseau à l'oiseau pas un foot
justement de telle sorte que le matin et
s'était imaginé que le soleil ne se
lèverait pas s'il n'était pas le chant
du coq nos deux pays et le temps à autre
il prétendait pondre des oeufs couvés et
cantons restent 2es journées ils les
occuper ce que je mange chanter vos
juillet nachi dans le vallon du plomb
dans l'eau
alors comment va le plus simplement du
monde un jour il sévit dans la tête
qu'ils pouvaient voler alors aidé son
chant du cygne
maintenant qu'il était rare est monsieur
on sait une nouvelle carrière
seymour quand même pas je reconnais que
c'est émouvant après avoir parlé pendant
je suis plus mûr 40 ans en tant de
belles choses
mon frère et moi maintenant voilà
habillé tous les deux effectivement
c'est c'est très émouvant
leriche convoité de carlo goldoni ce
nouveau riche un peu innocent ressemble
à un gagnant du loto assailli par l'état
peur
pourtant malgré tous les pièges galabru
michel lecomte horace ne s'en laissera
pas conter par les sirènes d'entre cour
et jardin